on the basis I think you should call a
spade a spade we've called it and what
it is and that is a modern-day slavery
but more importantly than having the
right name it may be very important in
that actually how we get prosecutions
successfully carried out well if you
lead on the front foot which is
trafficking it's the trafficking event
which has to be proved not the evil of
the exploitation and therefore what
we've tried to do and suggesting to the
government is being wonderfully opening
the whole of this process is to say that
we actually we need to do more than just
bring the three acts you currently use
together we need to think what is going
to be in the minds of the jury as a case
is revealed before them term human
trafficking isn't really that clear
either if you're a general voter slavery
something you can understand much more
quickly than human trafficking and it's
all credit to the Conservatives and the
pot all the parties you've been working
on this that it's become such a big
issue that the problem is though is that
there are still bits of the bill which
are missing as Frank has said it's quite
clear that home so he wants to have
supply chains in I think when number of
reasons first of all she wants the very
best bill going and it won't be the very
best bill going if in fact we don't have
the supply chanting secondly as you and
Isabel hinted it is extraordinary that
when willful started out slavery was
widespread in this country and accepted
Wilberforce had to raise the nation up
to be a opposed to what was common
practice now as Isabel said people are
poured by this back but it's hidden and
it's never more hidden them in the
supply chains and what we proposed in
the committee was that we attach to the
companies act a sub sub sub clause two
companies duties to report on human
rights to include modern-day slavery
and I think I I hope will win that
debate in that I think the Prime
Minister has a duty to actually protect
company directors from foolishly or
carelessly entering into activities
which are as appalling as human slavery
I think also politically that Theresa
May hasn't got her way on this is
another example of the fights she has
with number 10 which two people on the
outside those he'd been campaigning for
these very important changes seem
utterly baffling so if you look back at
her fight on the stop and search she was
thwarted by number ten in that she
eventually sort of succeeded and that
she was able to introduce voluntary
changes for the police but number ten
thought oh this will make me
conservative so because there was soft
on crime whereas actually she was trying
to address a huge injustice that many
people from the black and minority
ethnic communities have been complaining
about for a long time again modern
slavery it's very difficult to look at
this and think well why shouldn't we
include this bit about supply chains in
the bill but number ten said is possibly
anti-business and Theresa May is
fortunately for her politically on the
right side of this argument and number
ten is on the wrong side is about to
take you up on that because I think it's
very important you say number ten rather
than the prime minister because the
prime minister appears to me troubles
all the lights in actually running the
government and I think it's officials
thinking this is his mind and the Prime
Minister not actually getting round to
actually saying come on this is not
worth the candle and the choice that
he's going to have because it would be
posing in the comments we may not care
as in the corners it will be carried in
the Lord's now did the government
actually want to share credit for this
bill or do they want to be a totally
coalition bill if they do then they've
got actually just knuckle down and say
the Lord's will defeatist will be
dragged kicking and screaming online
shouldn't we actually just concede
what's inevitable anyway and this is a
strategic weakness that the government
has had on other pieces of legislation
as well I think you about the same sex
marriage but where it ended up actually
with Yvette Cooper managing to take a
great deal of the credit because it was
Labour's support that got that little
through even though it was David
Cameron's personal commitment I think if
you're a prime minister or a minister
who's committed to a bill you should
want to take the credit for that because
you go into government to change things
well i think is fine says it looks like
it's going to be a cross-party when
rather than a conservative victory which
is a shame because it's being introduced
by conservative government by
conservative Home Secretary but you've
got battles within the Conservatives
over the detail and the policy